a bunch of movie people just got
nominated for awards by a bunch of other
movie people yep it's Oscars time so get
ready for heartfelt speeches from actors
thanking everyone and their mother
literally and especially the Academy so
who is this mysterious Academy and how
do they pick their winners the Academy
is basically an exclusive club for movie
people there are more than 6,000 active
members and each one belongs to a
specific Academy branch from actors to
directors to writers how do you get in
if you're sponsored by two current
Academy members or if you've been
nominated for an Oscar yourself but
aboard makes a final approval seems
legit right yeah except the Academy's
come under a lot of fire for its lack of
diversity the LA Times track down
thousands of members in 2012 and found
that ninety-four percent of them were
white and seventy-seven percent were men
all with a median age of 62 maybe that's
why your favorite Romanian queer
post-feminist arthouse slasher pic
didn't win at the end of the year
Academy members nominate their top picks
in their branch and their top picks for
best picture that means directors
nominate other directors actors nominate
other actors and so on but also get to
list their favorite movies overall a big
problem here there's no way anyone could
ever watch the hundreds of movies that
are released every year in the u.s.
Academy member and director of Patriot
Games Phillip Noyce told us up for the
sake of the Oscars he watches 25 or 30
films then there's the awards themselves
once nominees are picked Academy members
vote for the winners but the big kahuna
the Oscar for Best Picture involves a
preferential ballot system based on how
members rank their pics Daily Beast
entertainment editor Marlowe Stern told
us the system quote pretty much ends up
favoring the least disagreeable movie
winning an Oscar is big business for a
movie studio and they invest a lot of
money in so-called Oscar campaigns
geared at Academy members one film
producer told the LA Times it's like an
arms race so if you're a big studio with
money to burn you're obviously at an
advantage over small indie companies
we're talking ads in Hollywood trade
publications billboards half our TV
spots and more racking up millions of
dollars not to mention swag sent to
movie
and others one director complained to
the hollywood reporter that the year the
movie Lincoln was nominated he got
everything short of Lincoln condoms in
the mail but Phillip Noyce told us he's
never received anything more than a DVD
screener and maybe some cheap wine at a
movie party it's not really anything you
could call for free so that's the
glamorous process behind the Oscars do
you think it's fair or are you really
only in it for the fancy gowns
you